[MUSIC PLAYING]
This episode was proudly
made possible by Subaru.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
For as long as I
can remember, I've
had a soft spot for
love and melancholy.
And I think those two things are
intimately interrelated, right?
Love and sadness-- they
exist in the same space.
There's a reason the
filmmaker Cameron
Crowe uses the term happy, sad
to describe those moments that
move us, that swell us, that we
become engorged with emotions.
And we're also a
little bit like,
oh man I'm not so sure if
that's making me that happy
or if I'm sad-- I
can't really tell.
And Roland Barthes explored
this beautifully in his book
"A Lover's Discourse."
There's a couple lines
in it that I really love.
He says--
"The first thing
we love is a scene,
which is seen for
the first time.
Curtain parts, and what
had never been seen
is devoured by the eyes.
It's distinct, abrupt, framed.
It is already a memory."
And this is the line
that really gets me.
This idea that when
we're struck by love,
it is Immediately
already a memory.
The moment is happening,
and you're already
mourning the fact that
the moment will end.
This intertwining of melancholy,
of loss, that is literally
embedded in the
experience of rapture
is what's so unique and
mesmerizing about love
but also what
makes it so tragic.
Right?
There's a reason
that Roland Bathes
cites love as, "the
romantic solution
to the problem of death."
That our lovers act as
stand-ins in a staged, managed,
resurrection.
Where the pilgrim without
faith can die and live again.
These death and
re-birth simulations
allowing us to finally--
to turn our lovers
into Gods and Goddesses.
To be saved by them.
It's every pop song,
it's every romantic movie
you've ever seen.
You know the feeling,
it moves us to tears.
But who cares.
Because as Camus
says, "Life should
be lived to the point of tears."
So, fall in love, or die trying.
Right?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Be sure to check out
a Second Chance Subaru
at revision3.com/subaru.
[MUSIC PLAYING]